we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's just a little break from the from
the depressing politics
there's a really funny debate going on
in our audience right now
about whether i am providing too much of
a
setup for the video and audio clips that
i play on the show
here's a caller who thinks i should be
providing more of a setup take a listen
to this
hi david i'm calling in heavy support
of your usual format
of pre-loading us before you play a clip
in normal presenting of information
i love the idea of getting straight to
the content and then analyzing it after
and i respect those who
requested that however when it's in the
case of
stuff coming out of the republican uh
the trump administration
uh or trump itself it is so full of spin
and guest lighting which is
kind of abusive that preloading us with
information for me
really helps relieve the pain
of uh of having to hear it and it also
it it is a a um like a vaccination
against the upcoming spin
it makes me look much more immune to it
when it actually uh
hits so i'm in strong support of your
pre
front loadings okay so
my idea for years has been i'm not like
uh
uh i'm not a video playback technician
the idea here is i'm giving you my take
and so
i try to prepare people for what we're
going to see and i
certainly give more of a lead up to
clips than some other hosts
might and it was deliberate i was doing
that on purpose
and every once in a while i would get
emails from people saying david
just give us the clip and then analyze
it so that you're not tainting our view
and and sort of priming us to believe
one thing or the other
then after tell us what you think and by
that time we'll have made made our own
uh sort of judgment of it and i tried
that yesterday and i've tried it a
little more recently
and i have to tell you overwhelmingly
overwhelmingly the reaction was no no
david don't just play the clips don't
you
don't be a video playback clerk
essentially
we are here for you to give us context
and the context before is actually
important so
this is not a huge deal it's an
interesting difference of opinion among
the audience
but a point taken and the response
overwhelmingly in the last 24 to 48
hours is
please go back to the old way tell us
what we're about to see and we can still
say we disagree with you
but we like to see what is your take on
what we're about to see so i'll probably
go back
in that direction we have a great bonus
show for you today one of the things i
want to talk about is
why is the post office being discussed
in business terms and what i mean by
that is
the post office is a public service and
president trump and his donor postmaster
general lewis de joy
they're talking about it like it's a
business and it should be evaluated and
handled like a business that is supposed
to turn a profit
that's not actually what it's supposed
to do and i want to address that on the
bonus show
we're also going to talk about the
reality that donald trump although he is
now assailing the character of kamala
harris actually donated to her multiple
times
we'll talk about that uh and then lastly
lebanon's leaders were warned in july
about explosives at the port according
to some documents and we are going to
explore that in detail all of this is on
the bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com and remember august
23rd
the 15-year anniversary of the david
pakman show
we will have a huge one-day membership
special to be notified of that special
get on my newsletter it's free at
davidpakman.com